We're going to look now at configuring your Burp Suite Enterprise Edition server to use
an HTTP proxy. If your organization does not allow your Enterprise server to connect directly
to the internet, you will need to configure Enterprise to use an HTTP proxy server to
reach external domains. Enterprise requires external access to activate the license and
perform automatic software updates, so these settings are for the Enterprise server itself.
If a scanning machine needs to use a proxy server to access a scanning target,
this is set separately under the scan configurations. From the settings menu, select network.
Scroll down and select use an HTTP proxy server.
Enter the IP address or name of your proxy server and the port it uses.
If your proxy server requires authentication, you can also add it here.
And if you're using an unauthenticated proxy, you can also use this to connect to an SMTP server.
Once you're happy, click save and you're ready to go.
You can also use an unauthenticated proxy server.
If you're using an unauthenticated proxy server, you can use an unauthenticated proxy server.